well I think you know one of the things
that you learn in law school pretty
early on is that people are incoherent
that you can't people have motives that
they don't even understand on their own
they don't understand their lives and
your clients come in and they tell you
their problems they may not be telling
you the truth and you have to try to
figure out what the truth is all kinds
of people mixed up and you can't really
expect coherence from them and I think
that people who have studied Jefferson
more so than other areas maybe it's
because he's a founding father maybe
this is something that's a people fall
prey to when they're thinking about
founding fathers expect a kind of
coherence from them that really is not
realistic and then when he's not going
coherent they get mad at him and they're
critical of him because he's not
coherent when I think my training as a
lawyer we try to teach our students from
the very beginning that people are sort
of crazy and by nature and you can't
expect all of this stuff to fit so I
think that kind of view of the world in
forms I don't go in and say oh it's
impossible for this person to have felt
that it's impossible for this person to
do that no nobody would ever do that
because people be able to start rational
and they don't work that way and so that
sensibility informs I think my work